now guys I know you don't all share
scenes with them you guys are in a movie
with three Oscar winners because they're
added pressure when you're going to your
project when there's that kind of
pedigree in the rest of the cast
I say yeah for me and you when you look
at the cast list it as a young actor you
know you can only at least personally I
can only hope to to be recognized and in
that way and then I hear that your skill
loved one and that your acting ability
gets recognized like that so you know it
made me want to want to really work hard
and really come to play when I was on
set yeah I think I think I was nervous
when I saw them you know signing on you
know I got the role in like a week later
Christoph signs on and Jennifer just
kind of this pinball effect so that was
the most nerve-wracking thing but when
you get on set and you see these people
you realize they're just like you know
probably exactly way more talented but
you know that they're just geeks they
love they love acting too and they love
movies so you know we're kind of all in
the same and that were in that respect
so do you find like you're kind of like
trying to steal some kind of like some
tips any kind of lay I mean at least for
me you know days that I wasn't working I
would I was on set just like watching
because I really felt I wanted to learn
everything I possibly could from them
and we got so lucky we have these
mentors and teachers right there in
front of us but exactly the King said
like they are there they were so
welcoming and so just Dadar with real
people and so when you actually do get
to meet them that intimidation that you
might have originally had going into the
into the film really went away pretty
quickly yeah let's talk about the
spectacle of his before audiences review
guys I know a lot of it was practical
and set like real sets but what's it
like for you guys to see the final
product all come together like this
visual feast
like it was so amazing the first time I
saw it I literally did not know what to
expect I forgot everything like I forgot
a lot about I just forgot I'm so sitting
there in the screening room I'm watching
it by myself and I was just like every
scene you're hungry for more and it's so
visually stimulating and incredible like
I can't wait to watch it again yeah yeah
I mean youyou you're you're shooting
you're shooting one thing and that one
thing is really cool don't get me wrong
but then you see it on the big screen
for the first time there's also there's
also the first time you're seeing you
know myself honestly anyway so that was
just you know yeah the scope and scale
and the world building is unlike any
movie I've ever seen obviously except
for Avatar for whatever well I'm sorry
well the question so in terms of the
spectacle of the movies doesn't yeah I
mean I feel like words can't really do
it justice I feel like it's really
something you got to experience yourself
and something that hopefully you can see
in the movie theater and the way that
you know all of us you know want the
audience's to see it so they can get the
whole spectacle of it all yeah now if
you two tried to get part in the sequel
to all the boys ever before yet it's an
opportunity
I tested and she would look at me she
wouldn't even look at me the second one
now come on all right
I heard of that they've heard of it but
none of them have ever been like yeah
we'd like to be in it cuz they don't
want to be in this oh come on did you
read that it works at all like this
second the third oh yeah I read the
second not the third so don't want to
get too ahead of myself from the brain
and I loved it so I can't wait to see so
yeah thank you
you